[Music]
if you welcome to the Deshawn idiot hole
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
already miss Puerto Rico have you heard
of her I didn't until just recently when
she made some just some outlandish and
crazy I mean really crates she sent some
crazy tweets out you know about Michael
Moore
he went out said we're all Muslims he
had a sign going against a lot of the
crazy rhetoric that was coming from some
of these politicians why just spewing
hate and spreading fear and somehow this
sad poor girl she got involved in a mix
of this mix of things so she's from a
Puerto Rican descent and she said some
really hurtful things against Muslims so
we're gonna go ahead and hopefully miss
Puerto Rico be watching his too and
we'll kind of go ahead and give her a
response to the tweets she had some
really nasty hurtful things to say it
hurts but we're gonna give her some love
but first we got to give her a response
and guess what from her Puerto Rican to
we'll be right back
[Music]
please be with you how are you my smile
rocks a lot everything is well how's
everything with you Miss Puerto Rico
have you heard of her yes I have okay
she like famous is she big in total Rico
recently she's gained fame through the
her comedies yeah Muslims we don't watch
beauty pageants yeah we really respect
women to a higher level that's right
yeah
but there there are some things
obviously that she tweeted and we're
gonna give the response and at the end
we're gonna also you know what's
fascinating that sometimes you'll say
one word to someone you offend someone
they won't give you the light of day
they won't invite you in the house ever
again you're just caught off but even
with all the negative things she said
we'll give the response but still she'll
be welcomed with open arms and most of
Muslims if she changes her ways is that
true that's for sure yes for sure
so should we get into the tweets
definitely let's get okay let's get into
tweet number one this is from Miss
Puerto Rico and we got a Puerto Rican
who's no stranger to the DS show Michael
Moore you know he held up the sign we're
Muslims and he was trying to go against
the hate spew that many of these
politicians before I get into the tweet
what are your thoughts on that you know
there's a lot of Islamophobic rhetoric
hate rhetoric and what are your thoughts
are you feeling the heat but you're from
New Jersey neighbor to New York
yeah maybe it's New York New Jersey for
me it's not too much different than what
happened after 9/11 we received the same
hate the same you know the same violent
messages and the same you know the same
disgusting things that you know people
did and said all over again right you
know for me it basically makes me feel a
little sad that you know we're we're
such a time and error in this country of
advancement that we're actually moving
backwards right going back to racism and
all of this type of hate that you know
happened a long time ago and we're
bringing this back to life where you
know we're trying to set that fire back
up again you know in the time and error
in which we are living it doesn't
make sense man no usually you know hate
breeds hate yes and I mean no good comes
from it so these politicians many they
take advantage of this there's the
ignorance of people and to push certain
agendas do you see you know spreading
this false fear because I mean anybody
like you yourself when you looked into
Islam did you feel like you had anything
to fear no no no I don't know I didn't
really know anything about Muslims I
didn't know what they believed in I
didn't know about terrorism Nadi these
things all I know is that you know these
people were worshiping one God and I
wanted to know why do they worship that
one God what do they truly believe in
how do they believe in it and get them
benefited out to see what their religion
codes were when I looked into it I found
something extremely beautiful and
hopefully miss Puerto Rico she'll also
benefit from this and she'll see the
same thing you did and many Latinos are
seeing she says Miss Puerto Rico to
response to Michael Moore she said hold
a sign that says we are believers in
Christ why are you why are you defending
Muslims that haven't done anything for
America or the USA you know first I
would have to give her some historical
context if she is a true Puerto Rican
true to the Puerto Rican pride and pride
of her culture pride of where she came
from and then I would ask her to go back
and read about how Puerto Rico came
about being the country it is now after
being colonized we see that our people
really weren't a people of Christian
faith and Christian belief the Spaniards
came in right Queen Elizabeth when she
came in and Columbus landed these
different things happened she said to
the Indians the only days you would have
free is if you come to worship on Sunday
and if you worship on Sunday you won't
be treated like a slave trying to go
into the mountains to pull out the gold
because it was called Puerto Plata the
port of money right because they thought
that they were going to go into the
mountains pull out all of this gold so
they began taking those days because it
was the only day that they could be free
they didn't have to live and toil and
struggle and work hard
and then when they found out that they
people that came to invade them were
actually human beings because they came
with muskets with guns so they've never
seen a gun before in their legs when
they told me were like gods
they came with famine and diseases the
Indians got sick and we're dying why
they didn't so they were thinking these
guys have to be gods
and when one finally stood up against
them and killed him they left him for a
couple of days because they wanted to
see is he going to come back to life and
when they found out that he didn't come
back to life then they said oh they die
just like we do we're human beings just
like we're human beings and they began
to defend themselves and to defend their
positions so I would ask her to go back
and read some of this history and are we
really people are are people really the
people of Christ or was that something
forced upon our people when you look at
you know contributions Muslims have made
I mean you look at you know from
medicine the first University built by a
woman that were benefiting from that
today you know pharmacy many of these
great scientists hadn't seen you have
for what's the lady who's running for
president Clara Lynn for chlorine she
had said she had praised Muslims before
now the Arabic numerals like so when she
this lady starts texting and using her
cell phone iPad all this stuff is on
behalf of I mean you can link it back to
Muslims contribution coffee that you
drink all of these things I mean the
things that that that you brought up you
know people don't they stuck with
terrorism with you know backwardness of
some some Arab lands they've had
dictators put upon them their best work
but when Muslims were in a position that
they were able to practice really
inviting Christians and Jews also to
live amongst them in peace Muslim lands
were flourishing and elusive Spain huh
that's right that's right and that's and
that's even bigger right when we look at
our culture my my generation my people
my family within my grandparent my
great-grandparents I have Spaniard
I have African I have native Indian
right Thai you know I have French and I
have European all mixed in just two
generations above me and my grandma
Lieber says that her father
was Spaniard her mother was the Taino
Indian right
she said my father used to speak with
words at times that we could not
understand and she tries to say them and
at times they sound like a beware Arabic
words hold it right there we're gonna
get we got to go to break hold on don't
lose that place a man really exciting we
got some more of your tweets to share
from Miss Puerto Rico and we're gonna
give her some love here from the Muslims
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show we got mr. Puerto
Rico in the house I'm addressing some of
these tweets continue where you left off
yeah so my grandmother she said that her
father who was a Spaniard he would speak
with words that sometimes she couldn't
understand and she tries to like mimic
the words and for me now learning Arabic
and learning about Islam the words
seemed like they were Arabic words we
know that within our culture because the
Arabs right the Muslims had Spain for
over 800 years that the Hispanic
language over two to three thousand
words in the Hispanic language derived
from the Arabic language one of the
words that we commonly use as Puerto
Ricans is ojala ojala Mira a way para
mañana ojala me pasa ojala que su pasa
right
Oh holla comes from oh Allah oh Allah
almost like if Allah wills tomorrow this
would happen if Allah wills hopefully
I'll achieve this if Allah wills
hopefully this would take place this is
a common word that we use or holla all
right and then you have words like
Pantalone right Pantalone Kami's cabeza
rules our rules right to show that our
culture is integrated intertwined with
the Muslim culture all right my African
side of the family when you look at the
Puerto Ricans in Puerto Rico there's
three customary types of dress you had
the European dress right the tight
dresses that flared out then you had the
local the native dress and then you had
the dress of the Africans the Puerto
Ricans are known for famous dance music
Carla Wamba and when you go and you look
up la Bamba they used to dress
with their heads covered and they used
to wear Brill baggy dresses all the way
down to the bottom of the to their
ankles the men they would wear these
things they almost look like Goofy's
almost at time some of them the African
ones we're like what would look like
almost like a African Islamic garment
and then if we switched over then you
will see men with white garbs you know
white kind of pants and shirt with a
with the old you know hat and we look at
this and we say well those roots go back
to those African roots go back to Islam
they were dressed like Muslims perhaps
were slaves who were brought in by the
Spaniards who were perhaps Muslim right
and they began to affect the land and
the people so we see that you know I
would I would advise her please go back
read the history see how our people are
connected to Islam and how closely our
culture and Islam the teachings of Islam
are almost one in the same yeah you
mentioned those slaves uh thirty to
fifty percent would it's a fact that
we're Muslims who were brought over I
guess their will to help actually make
this country yes yeah let's go on to the
next we got uh many tweets we were just
on one but I just want to cover this
real quick we are believers in Christ so
are we - that's right Christ you can't
be a Muslim unless you believe in Jesus
the Christ Messiah that's all it means
in Hebrew Christ means the Messiah and
you cannot be a Muslim unless you
believe and love Jesus is that right
that's for sure and this is one of the
biggest problems with at times with
ignorance Wayne Dyer he's a self-help
author he made a beautiful statement he
said the greatest form of ignorance is
to reject something you know nothing
about Wow
Allah Akbar right and Wally Amos the
cookie mogul
he said minds function best when they
work like a parish should open right so
we open our minds and we begin to not
reject things that we don't nothing
about right we get to see how things
really are right and then we see that
when we look at the whole issue of
Christ and we look at Islam Christ is
one of the five greatest messengers said
to mankind we ask
love Christ we absolutely love Jesus if
we don't love Jesus you're not a
believer right his beloved mother Mary
has been given a whole chapter in the
Quran chapter 19
after named after her the chapter of
Mary right may Allah be pleased with her
so we have to love we have to love Jesus
and changed that misconception that that
Muslims don't believe in Jesus we
absolutely believe in Jesus we follow
him we believe like in the verse that's
in the Bible that he is the way he was
delight meaning his guidance was the way
his guidance was the light that leads
you to allah subhanho wa taala to God
Almighty going onto the next one
she said all miss Puerto Rico tweeted
all what Muslims have done is provided
oil and terrorized this country and many
others
Aloha coddled all Muslims have done is
provide oil and terrorized countries and
many others you mentioned all of the
beautiful additions that Islam brought
to the world Islam took the world out of
darkness into light engineering
mathematics planes clocks medicine if it
wasn't for the contributions of the
Muslims we wouldn't have many of the
things that we have today the Muslims
have also come to this country and
because this statement revolves around
ignorant not knowing what the Muslims
contribute right because Muslims are not
just Arabs from Muslim countries that
have oil but we've come come to this
country most of the doctors in this
country are Muslims you go to the
hospital you may be treated by a Muslim
doctor right engineers working for NASA
setting spaceships into space taking
care of the satellites creations by
Muslims in Rockford where I lived in
Rockford
some of the Muslims were the creators of
some of the most amazing inventions that
are out in space right now so how can we
say that Muslims are not contributing
anything to the world we're making a
beautiful contribution and will continue
to make a bit of a contribution to the
world because we believe that we add to
the world's beauty and we don't take
away from the world
and the data doesn't lie you can see
right now FBI reports from early 1980 up
until 2000 before 2010 94% of terrorist
attacks had nothing to do with Islam and
Muslims also euro poll shows 1% of
attacks less than Muslims you've had
over close to 200 over 180,000 this is
an old statistic moving on to 200,000
deaths Americans killing Americans that
went on since 9/11 and most of these
only 40 were done by someone who's
connected to Islam being Muslims the
rest are people that have nothing to do
with Islam or Muslims this far you have
355 plus mass shootings just your city
or a load more than a number of days and
now you have these sad incidences just
one is tragic enough mr. Porter Rico
probably doesn't know like the average
layman that 350 plus were not they had
nothing link with Islam or being Muslim
it's two of those are linked back to
being Muslim so you see the the numbers
Muslims are the most peaceful Muslims
are the most charitable the most
well-mannered you'll see Muslims all
your neighbors get to know um we got
right we got a Puerto Rican Muslim and a
Muslim is what one who submits and
surrenders to the crate or not the crazy
loves Jesus to we right back with a
little more time definitely be right
back and show log I want peace please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we covered two
before I went to break put the
statistics putting things into
perspective and there was actually
Hiroshima on a light switch have you
heard of that you know Hiroshima and
Nagasaki yes yes you hear the Hiroshima
on a light switch Hiroshima with a light
switch the weapon would be mobile
shooting concentrated doses of radiation
on unsuspected targets who would die
within two weeks among the potential
target sources say Muslims and President
Obama on a light switch using a small
workshop on this property to start
developing it
the Crawfords live here with to chew
with their three children rather
immediately afterward broke out members
of their church started coming here to
pray for them they were unaware of the
details that surrounded their rest and
unaware that crawford was a
self-proclaimed member of the Ku Klux
Klan
he's also accused of carrying an
animosity toward Muslims and targeting
them in this attack members of the
parkersville Christian Church say they
are shocked by this and think it's all a
mistake
adding the Crawfords are nice giving
people who aren't the types that would
be involved in a terrorist group the
[Music]
dramatic moment federal authorities
busted Glendon Scott Crawford all
captured on surveillance tapes in a
schaghticoke warehouse the Crawford
detailed his plan to undercover FBI
agents posing as white supremacist he
meets with them here at a Schenectady
hotel and you hear two incriminating
conversation with the Undercovers
showing them what Crawford called a
radiation poisoning chart it would be
weeks before anybody they had tried
tried it out initially on the before the
arrests that happened they turned on the
device they proved that it worked they
didn't turn on the radiation portion of
it so that's what they were saying today
but they had at least tested it to make
sure that it did work just not that
radiation because they don't want to
harm themselves the complaint says that
Crawford called its capabilities
Hiroshima on a light switch saying
radiation poisoning is a beautiful thing
the intended targets individuals he
referred to as medical waste
specifically Muslims and people
perceived to be enemies of Israel could
this device as specified here actually
carry out the crime they want to do an
admit deadly x-ray radiation the answer
was clearly yes and range was 180 months
and the judge gave him almost half of
that and I don't think we could have
asked too much more from the judge
so in light of that I think it was not a
terrible day for us
London Crawford sat silently in court as
prosecutors laid out new details in an
alleged plot to emit dangerously high
levels of radiation targeted at Muslims
eventually fight was sentenced to eight
years and one month in prison one of the
lowest sentences the judge could impose
I had actually saw that you had posted
something on it I haven't been able to
watch it just we had something this was
also on a Christian KKK type again
people think you're crazy to link this
back to you know mainstream Christianity
that's the same way people like Miss
Puerto Rico whoever link back a fringe
element doing crazy things you know in
the name of Islam has nothing to do
Islam just like these these these
maniacs deranged people who want what
I'm weapon of mass destruction most
people don't hear about the 355 mass
shootings but they hear about Muslims
one any time on anything with Muslims
its mainstream this way it's
wall-to-wall coverage but when it's
someone who's non-muslim local news
quickly goes away you don't hear it
right terrorism it not connected no
religion not even the race of the people
come on that's crazy let's go to her she
says our mission is critical
there's no comparison between Jews
Christians and Muslims Jews what
Christians have terrorising agendas in
their sacred books and for us and
hopefully you'll be able to clarify this
inshallah in terms of maybe given the
people some statistics and some verses
and things of that nature because I
haven't memorized them all but clearly
within the Bible there are verses
actually just recently some guys they
put together and they took a vibe when
they covered it Abajo cooked and there's
your uncle Topher Tilton go on even
heaven was hoping the passaggio sky
highlights he's there can contrast an
but also Wester should normal
environment in sky covered Hobart also
adopted the Bible for like an immense
upstart marcelina for the standing lava
that's at the Quran comer also minds of
ordinary faith and also sealed from on
the valley of Allah George dollars
fleece from the egg zone aid and its
place
a doctor's sultanate understand me - lot
of our own eyes cave the mutia hunter of
haka laughs - oh I need to see Rene
among metal on the Lamaze class
assignment as a cat or the dog - Brock
water and he started opening up in
reading the reading the verses and the
people like oh my god
they supposed affairs you know the Quran
Bama Congress had the Bible Accords and
is full the Seder my nakedness for
instance Nate that's in your book oh my
god I can't believe that gee your book
and you says that and then they pulled
the cover off and it was a Bible that
went viral that video that went viral
that video right and it's just like you
know these things are also found in the
Bible right every culture of people
every religion has some form of violence
but we see right there's a good book
that was written by imam via e-mail xia
zi a and his called islam silencing the
critics in this book he gives such a
beautiful account of how he brings
verses from the Bible how the bible in
the bible the jews and the monasteries
had to defend themselves and God gives
them the right to defend themselves
because if they weren't didn't have the
right to defend themselves the
monasteries the churches all of the
places of worship would have vanished so
God had gave them the right to defend
themselves and to fight and to you know
hold up to the you know to try to hold
up the Word of God all of this is in the
Bible it's in the Torah you find some of
it in the Koran right and it was an
issue of defense and when we look at
Islam all of those verses that the
people try to use those are issues of we
have the right to defend ourselves but
we had better than the Geneva Convention
1400 years ago right the Geneva
Convention is new Muhammad SAW you said
on 1400 years ago he said in war you're
not to cut down a tree you're not to
harm a woman you're not to harm a child
you can only fight the person who's
fighting
and if they cease fighting and they seek
out a Treaty of Peace then you make
peace before the Geneva Convention that
Islam was already promoting that the
Geneva Commission took its principles
from Islam
yeah then when you put things in
perspective you see like if you want to
play that game you open up the Bible I
mean you open up a can of worms we
respect the Bible that's right right we
believe there is the Word of God in it
the word of prophecy historians and an
animus books we don't know who is
writing many of these things and you
have things in there that now we would
disagree with you know what I mean
you have Jesus who's allegedly saying
for my enemies who now wish that I'm not
reign over them bring him here and cut
them in front of me that's--it's it
slaughtering that's it I mean Miss
Puerto Rico maybe he's never had never
heard that but now many people haven't
now if you read you know whole towns are
called upon to be massacred women
children you don't have any of that in
Islam again we don't want to belittle or
insult our intention is that anybody any
of our Christian brothers and sisters
out there humanity we just want to
clarify and respond to miss Porter
Rico's text that now if you look at
Islam the Quran there's nothing in a
historical context that goes against any
human beings rights does injustice to
anybody cause of killing innocent people
if you read a verse before or after in
the Quran you won't find any of that
will you yeah if your enemies want to go
towards peace put the what the orphans
now go towards peace that's right that's
right
Allah is always calling us to be the
most just because he says verily he
loved those who are just Allah is the
most just he loves those who are just so
Allah is always teaching us to be just
and it's unfortunate that you know the
other contribution that Islam has made
in our day and era was to make people
extremely rich Hollywood has been making
a lot of money with the boogeyman
all right the terrorist movies all of
the movies has what Muslims Allah
Muhammad the cells the secret cells the
terrorist cells they make a killing off
of using our religion in our way of life
which does not teach that and
unfortunately because people allow the
TV
be the educator rather than going into
history and really reading and learning
and not remaining ignorant because the
TV becomes the educator because FoxNews
becomes the educator then we get
ignorant statements like this poor woman
made and I don't blame her completely I
just hope that Allah will guide her and
that she would at least open up to maybe
do some reading read the Quran for
yourself
that's one of the advice I would read
the Quran for yourself and see if you
find within it that which you claim is
within it and if you don't now at least
admit to that it's covered we're we got
a couple more minutes before I want to
get to at least do a couple more of
these what we'll we'll put them together
where Miss Puerto Rico had tweeted that
Muslims use our Constitution to
terrorize the US and plant gas stations
again with the gas station another tweet
the Islamic God is not the same god of
the Jews the Christians and the Jews I
don't think we have time for more but
just in a summary with when you look at
is that the Islamic God is not the god
of the Christians and Jews that was one
of the reasons why I became Muslim the
Bible guided me to Islam the one verse
just because of the shortness of time
was when Jesus peace be upon him may
Allah forever be pleased with him that
he was on the cross and he says my God
my God why has thou forsaken me he was
crying to the same God I cried soon when
he prostrated in the VAT in the in the
woods he was pressured into the same God
I was pressure into when he said God
removed this cup from me
he was supplicating to the same God I
supplicate to Jesus has taught me to
supplicate to pray to follow to obey to
love the God the creator of the heavens
and earth the one who created all of us
and the one whom we all will stand in
front of and the one whom we should be
obeying respecting loving and revering
this is what Jesus has taught me so for
them to say it's not the same God it's
absolutely the same God the same God
that Jesus prayed to testimony principle
what's wrong with gas stations we all
need s right how you gonna drive your
car again that's just you know
ridiculous you know
gas stations like I said then what about
them the hospitals are you stopped going
again medicine
and get it treated you know I mean
because exactly so you know you catch
cancer you're not gonna go to the doctor
because he's Muslim
ya know treat me you know yeah let's
move on something that we got one more
minute let's let's what I I the Salam
says love all mankind and we even for
the haters they've been so many people
who've been haters at the end they felt
the warmth of the Muslims they felt the
generosity and now is their hope now
someone came back in and even if she did
accept there's only one God wish to
create another creation you know and
accepted Islam as many are doing many
are women also but she just said you
know look I apologize and she wanted to
come to a Muslim convention whatever
that go visit or Muslim house when was
Muslims open their doors with love to
invite her in and give her this love I
would personally open my doors there she
can come visit me anytime feel free to
call me let me up on Facebook send me a
message I'll invite her over for some
rice and beans some steak with onions
you know one of our favorite staples and
we could sit down and have a discussion
the man who drew the profit he became
Muslim all right so definitely there's
always that door of forgiveness that
door of mercy because Islam is a
religion of mercy Islam is a religion of
forgiveness right our Prophet SAW seldom
told us that whenever beauty is put
inside of something that changes it so
definitely we want to show you the
beauty that we have and she would be
able to meet whatever your family
everybody everybody open arms and
everybody yeah and not everybody my
family's Muslim
yeah and we'll all sit at the table
together and have a beautiful discussion
yeah or we can come visit her in Puerto
Rico yeah if she's living there we can
come visit her in Puerto Rico family in
Puerto Rico definitely still have family
in Puerto Rico a lot of my family still
there and we have a beautiful
relationship do you know I'm Muslim I
respect them because they're Christian
and I respect them and I respect their
faith they respect me and they respect
my faith and we love each other and I'm
proud to be a Puerto Rican I'm a Puerto
Rican Muslim right so I have never
changed my culture I don't eat the pork
I eat the beef now I don't drink right
I'd take the juice instead but I still
hold on to everything else for my
culture
beautiful thank you for helping us
respond to some of these tweets god
bless you and inshallah we'll see you
again this is like a little hide the
clients
and thank you all for tuning in
especially our guests today that
hopefully will be watching show Miss
Puerto Rico sent out these tweets no no
problem we got no hate we got nothing
but love as a Muslim community if you
have any questions call us
[Music]
1-866-376-8255 in in the link below
[Music]